so let me set up the question for you
first I've written it down they give you
this monstrous looking thing and then
they say I give up I don't want the
whole expansion which is kind of the
point behind the question they're not
looking for the whole expansion they
only want that you want to turn there's
not the coefficient of a particular term
in the expansion okay do you remember
the example we looked at this morning
with this x squared plus one on x.25
right
do you notice when we did that you had
the x squared terms you had the one on X
terms and then when you sort of collide
them together well X's and X's they
start to cancel and you got powers that
came out nicely like X to the 10 X to
the 7 4 etc okay in the same way here
clearly if I were to do this whole
expansion these X terms and these
whatever X terms are clearly going to
interact with each other and cancel each
other out so the question is how can I
take advantage of that knowledge knowing
that these two eventually are going to
dance in some way to give me these how
can they use that to avoid expanding the
whole thing I do have to write this
first line there's no way to get around
this first line really you can see what
I've done is I've just put in the
binomial coefficients I've turned this
into an extended version of itself done
the same with this and then I pause
let's have a look if I were to do this
in long form what would I do
the answer is there are four terms in
the first sell brackets there are three
terms in the next set of brackets and I
would have to say this times one two
three and then I have to go this times
one two three and I'd have to do that
all the way through to the end okay but
I don't have to look at this see this
Tokyo
do you notice that when I multiply it by
this guy and this guy I don't care what
it will end up with you won't get an X
to the zero tone you see that I don't
need to calculate one times this is not
going to give me an excuse either
because this is an X to the negative one
this term times this term is going to be
useless to me
but it would not contribute to the X to
the zero in the same way this
times this is also going to be worthless
to me it will not contribute to the X to
the zero because it's a as the next to
the minus two and there's nothing to
balance it out do you see that so I can
actually ignore a whole bunch of terms
and look straight to the ones that I
need for instance I dodged this with
this the reason why is because that is a
term that I want do you see it's a
constant term that's what X sub zero is
it's a constant so one times one is
going to fall apart of the X to the zero
term when I'm finished you okay so I'm
just gonna highlight them in one column
then I'm gonna go on to the next term
this one here can you see if you
multiply this by this it's useless it's
not going to give you an X to the zero
but if I multiply this by this you will
get mixed in zero term do you notice
that because there's an X to the 1
there's an excellent minus one and they
will cancel each other out so therefore
this term if it pairs up with this term
won't give you something that will
contribute lastly you've got an x
squared term here this is one of the fun
things about binomial expansion they've
become very predictable right this guy
has to match up at this one do you see
it x squared X to the negative two so
they're clearly going to come together
and give you an intercept of zero so I
Parham LP okay that loiter on the end
executors what'd they do with him the
answer is well if I'm only interested in
X to the zero terms do you notice that x
this or this or this none of them will
give you an extra 0 term there's no one
you can match up with right this is that
that poor guy who gets big loss on the
cricket team which I have no personal
experience that xq2 you can safely
ignore right it's never going to give
you an X to the 0 term no matter what
you're paired with ok so now that's all
I have to work out these are the terms
that are going to pair up so I'm going
to say therefore the coefficient of x to
the 0 is and I have to say this I have
to stay okay now I'm working something
different because you'll see why what
I'm writing is not going to be this
expansion it's just one tiny part of the
expansion that would give me this okay
so I'm going to fall it because that
I've used 1 times 1 is 1
what's the ripple I'm gonna give me
let's see I'm gonna have 3 times
negative 1/3 sorry yeah because this is
gonna cancel ok actually I'll just write
the X there because I'm canceling yes
times what what is this term here it's
gonna be yeah 4 over X do you do that
that's the rigged one and then he comes
blue one let's see here that's a plus 3x
squared on 9 does that look okay yeah
times this guy which is 4 on x squared
you ready yeah so I just goes up and
because I've done my selection of
pairing carefully you can see those
extra cancel those X Squared's will
cancel so now actually
the numbers I've got one 3/3 but it's
negative so that's gonna be -4 do you
rate yeah I'm only getting one or two
nights do you great yes okay great
over here three divided by nine is a
third and there's a four so this is 4
into 3 one takeaway 4 is negative 3 plus
one another is negative 1 and 2/3 yes so
of course if you wanted to you can go
ahead and you can expand it's healthy
but you're going to end up with think
about it how many times if I had
expanded this entire line how many terms
would there be on the next line before I
finished Tommy - well there will be 12
exactly right because you're going to
get three terms from here combining with
him then you'll get another three for
this one and then another 3 for this one
and so on
eventually those 12 terms will collapse
down things will cancel out but I don't
have to do that I already know the terms
that will cancel out to give me an X to
the 0 - okay and in the same way I could
ask for an x squared term I could ask
for an X cubed term whatever is
particular to the question that I'm
working you okay